ever since the first valor champions was
announced over a year ago we've known a
couple of things for certain we knew we
were gonna get some amazing valor and
gameplay and we knew that our first
champion would be crowned what we did
not know however was all the drama the
tournament would bring and we're barely
out of the group stage so if you don't
know what's happening or you're just
confused don't worry i'll explain
everything
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i always gotta remind you hit the
like button the subscribe button and to
ring that notification bell we're just
over a week in and valerie champions is
getting dramatic false positive covet
cases cipher cam exploits an entire
region being upset at one team player
it's been a heck of a few days unless
you're like my fellow host keith who
deleted his twitter i am pretty sure you
saw what went down between shazam
zombs and what feels like the entire fan
base of brazilian valorant if you're not
completely up to date with what's
happened don't worry i have this
timeline for you but before we get into
it let me just say we are all going to
be completely respectful and
understanding more importantly if you're
going to be xenophobic hateful
problematic
you don't belong here you're part of a
community of literally millions act like
it so now that we've gotten that out of
the way what has happened the past week
in order to understand the complete
context of this we got to back it up to
december 2nd when sentinels faced furia
it was close it was 1-1 and sentinels
just needed one more round to close out
the series however fury was being
furious aka bosses and they were making
an insane comeback there's a sliver
there is a slither right back just as
you say can they find a way to manage
this though tens lining up at the back
wall all the sentinels players firing
off together in cosmic very important
flank through there's the hole too
can you find it
still fury are alive the rebel clutch
their forensic er
are you a believer sean i'm a believer
dan that is insane momentum was on their
side the rounds were exciting and nail
biting and then
attack pause a pause of any kind is
frustrating but the map's gonna pick up
soon right
no no
not at all it wasn't a minute or two
long tech pause it was a really long
time like i almost fell asleep watching
the broadcast long
it was like 20 minutes after we returned
from the pause sentinels won that last
round and closed out the series listen
tech pauses happen all of the time
they're necessary it seems like this
tournament specifically can't escape
them it leaves lots of time for poster
dudes like little like dances but this
tech pause was particularly annoying and
honestly upsetting the pause happened
because of a specific jump that he made
onto a box on top of c what he did was
not an exploit but rather a skill jump
but time was taken to make sure that it
was legal but we the audience aka the
viewers didn't know that what we saw on
our screens at the end were the
sentinels were turning to the desk so
some people like myself saw tens and
shazam coming back and thought maybe
sentinels had initiated it personally i
saw tens holding his neck coming back so
i thought it was like an injury or
something i talked to dapper after that
match about what happened to what she
simply replied yeah that was theirs
yeah yeah
so an unfortunate tech pause that
arguably should not have happened nor
taken that long for a simple skill jump
but this is where our story really
begins people were livid as sentinels
thinking they initiated the tech paws to
stall furyo's momentum and win the
series there's lots of hate being sent
their way including allegedly death
threats people were photoshopping
shazam's head onto a stock body photo
because shazam explained that he just
asked to go to the bathroom since the
tech falls was so long shazam admitted
this was weird because in the past this
wasn't allowed shazam later explained
his thoughts on stream about everything
that was happening on twitter all these
like really large brazilian influencers
are like beaming and clowning me on
twitter like talking [ __ ] like
shamelessly
without even knowing what happened
i literally just went to take a piss
it's actually really [ __ ] up it really
disappoints me so that happened but
we're not nearly done on december 3rd
vivo key defeated ascend 2-1 one of
those maps was breeze however people
began to notice that there may have been
an actual exploit used by vivokeed you
see there's a place on breeze
specifically a site where if you're
defending and you're cypher you can
place his camera where it glitches
through the texture and is an unfair
advantage and this sounds familiar we've
done a video on this before the bug in
question revolves around cipher's spy
cam it allows cypher to see a sight on
breeze without the attackers being able
to see the cam unless they push further
into the site the tldr of this is that
that camera is an exploit which teams
knew they were not allowed to use before
the event and teams have been punished
before for using it specifically x10 and
vodafone giants so there is precedent
and riot after an arguably long time
made the decision that this camera was
indeed an illegal exploit and that vk
would be penalized six rounds for it
those six rounds would make ascend win
breeze
and then technically the series and then
all hell breaks lose
justice for key begins to trend on
twitter people are upset and people
pointed fingers at other people like
dapper from sentinel saying they used
the same camera but did not receive any
punishment i can say that a colleague of
mine and myself checked out the vibe
where people were throwing accusations
at dapper of using that camera and the
positioning looks a little bit different
also from not part of this tournament we
have clips of dapper using a different
camera spot dapper himself denies using
the camera x-play now after the initial
ruling riot said hey we're actually
going to review this one more time and
they eventually decided that they're
going to replay the map with ascend up
seven after discussing the situation
with the emea team ascend eventually won
huge huge props of evoked for tying up
that match as well i talked to the coach
of evoked and this is what he had to say
regarding the exploit yes they did
receive a list
the list has a few pictures but
that one part is
in a zlatan has no pictures so they
should have paid more attention
and
they have been practicing using that
camera for a while it's not something
that they were like surprised and
decided to do then
even because like they're
it was not their intention like oh hey
let's abuse a bug
since like
cypher didn't didn't go to the same bomb
all the time and if they won like one
round because of that it was too much
but
that it wasn't your intention to be like
i'm gonna exploit something on december
4th we all wake up to a bunch of tweets
from players in berlin saying that like
something really upsetting and sad has
happened but we have no clue what
eventually we find out that there are a
bunch of false positive kova tests and
everything and everyone is okay but that
is not the biggest piece of drama that
would happen that day on december 4th at
1 12 p.m eastern time shazam sends out a
tweet
should have called a tech pause he
tweeted this during team vikings versus
gambit and
honestly what happened was a choke
viking should have had it in the bag so
shazam makes a joke in light to the
sentinels the furious situation but
people didn't take it as a joke shazam
then went back and forth in a serious
conversation with gustavo milao who is a
brazilian commentator and presenter for
valrant and then zombs enters the thread
can't wait to beat your [ __ ] region
again and this is when all hell breaks
loose gustavo tries to reply to this to
which zombs replied oh no if you're
seeing a pattern zombs then doubles down
on his rhetoric on his twitter almost an
hour later he then posted another tweet
about brazil and a screenshot of the
highest earners and valorem
which is him and the rest of the
sentinels enzymes is not wrong or even
exaggerating about the punishment part
of his tweets after the [ __ ] region
comment people were calling for zombs to
be punished under vct competitive rules
specifically there are some parts of
section 7 where people saw the rules
being most applicable to what zombs said
it should also be said that there is a
precedent of players being punished
under this section one being version 1
zelsis for a remark he made you don't
know what he said but he was suspended
from the vct some people thought it was
funny and all the essence of esports but
others like the co-ceo of furious said
that quote as the co-ceo of fury esports
and brazilian i truly would like to see
this kind of behavior be punished
accordingly it cannot happen esports is
about respect passion love disrespect
220 million people a lot of them living
in poverty is unacceptable zombies began
trending on twitter with tens of
thousands of tweets and the next day he
triples down not trying to be that
person but i should probably say the
next day zombs and the rest of the
sentinels were eliminated from the
tournament now i've been able to speak
to a number of coaches and players in
the vct and i wanted to get their
thoughts on this because this is a
pretty big deal i know it may seem like
petty drama and banter but remember
sentinels were allegedly sent death
threats and brazilian fans and players
feelings were seriously hurt it turned
out to be more than just tweets i know
it's corny or whatever but words can
seriously hurt people i asked furious
zand after their elimination if he had
been looking forward to facing sentinels
again and this is what he said well uh
one step at a time first
i don't believe
that sentient is a great team and it
would be really good to face them
uh not just for me but because there are
some people there who are being [ __ ]
talking our region and our nation and
saying things the bad things about our
day-to-day life and our daily
difficulties
so
more than just for the match it would be
great to be able to face them for myself
for personal reasons and to shut them up
a little it should be noted that iferiya
had won that set they would have faced
sentinels once again i asked the head
coach of crew and my new twitter mutual
friend about this tweet he had made
regarding region rivalries and he
explained that he doesn't really like
that whole head-to-head idea and he
would like to see a different
environment i would like to see you know
an environment uh
with more freedom you know i i don't i
don't like
to to win a game and hurt the
people from our region you know ladam
are making
jokes about
brazil being bad because we are we are
very very close we have a lot of friends
uh for example uh
uh
knows where a player from fourier
was my teammate in another game a few
years ago we are very close to girl so i
i don't like that kind of real
between regions maybe with between
between teams i think banter
it's okay uh to have banter between both
both things or two teams but
when we talk about when we talk about
regions
we
wake up you know
feelings about
nationalism politics and other things
that
i think they don't have a place here
because it's it's an important and and
should be and should be a healthy one
fun fact i asked his player klaus about
what he thought about all of this and he
said i don't care to be honest i also
asked heath and coy from vivokeed about
the situation and this was their
response
well i believe the people and regions
should be united and we should support
each other even if something grotesque
happens
we should always be get together and
support each other instead of going
against each other basically that's what
i think it's kind of a pity
he doesn't really enjoy the kind of
public attitude and the
being offensive in social media
since they play with so much like
feeling sometimes even they can pass the
limit like the game yesterday where they
were fighting with so much like
force of oil since it was a really hard
game and then started behind
and sometimes you can you can get in the
mood and actually like extrapolate what
you're trying to say maybe even get a
little bit offensive
but he thinks that the community should
be more united and actually cheer for a
team and to protect the team the way
it's meant to be and not with like hard
offenses and stuff like happen and
that's pretty much it since then
sentinels has been eliminated from
champions and people have memed on them
and still are
but that does not take away from the
seriousness of the situation and
vivokite and fury are also eliminated
from the tournament which i know really
stings for brazilian fans especially
after everything that has happened being
sent death threats and hate is not okay
in any way shape or form and also
everyone's feelings about what was said
about the region is valid a blanket
statement like that like or nor said can
bring up a lot of feelings that are not
related to esports all in all champions
is not over so let's just hope that the
event can just be the event and we can
all just enjoy valerian at its pinnacle
like it's supposed to be
which not to be that person
is pretty dang awesome
and we're barely even out of the group
stages
so
let's just enjoy it
[Music]
you